yeah that is how I enter professional
mode by the way how's up guys my name is
general welcome to episode 5.5 of Sparky
game engine where we're going to take a
look at more of an extension to episode
5 so in episode 5 we created this matrix
class that we had over here is capable
of handling a four by four matrix and
whatnot today I'm going to introduce
something else like more of a kind of a
cool trick we can use to address the
data at our matrix a bit differently
okay
so right now what we have is this
elements float and if we want to do
something like I don't know I want to
change an individual element of the
matrix I want to be like you know what
or I want to retrieve something I want
to be like positioned on elements at
index maybe I want like I don't know
okay let you say this is this is our
translation matrix right so we know that
the 12th 13th and 14th index are x y&z
respectively so I can be like 12 let's
set that to 2 right or I can access 12
in the same way I have to call by 12
right what a matrix 4 is really if we go
over here to this drawing board and we
take a look at it
right is it's obviously just it's
obviously just a bunch of values right
it's a bunt well it's a bunch of values
that happens to be 16 different values
yeah here we go 16 different values but
as you can probably notice they are
grouped into columns I guess it illegal
to run column major ordering right and
these columns right are each vak fours
okay so these vac fours there's four vac
fours essentially and we might we might
be like you know what I want to retrieve
this vac four and I want to address it
like I want to basically interpret it as
being a vector 4 yeah that's all I
wanted to be I just want it to be a four
component vector I don't want to have to
deal with four variables or I don't want
to have to deal with these indices
separately I want to be like I want the
I want this column
and I want it to be evac'd for okay so
what someone might do okay is something
on the lines of they might make a like a
avec for and let me just include that
for real quick there might be like let's
make a vac for called get column it'll
take in and index and what it will do is
just simply return a brand new vac for
consisting of elements elements at index
basically this right where you have
elements at index n plus 1
men plus 2 then plus 3 and of course you
need to multiply that index I can't see
the keyboard multiply that index by 4
okay so someone might do something like
this and it would pretty much work right
it would do that but the unfortunately
what it's doing is it's actually
constructing this okay its constructing
a brand new that for the problem with
this is is going to allocate a whole new
block of memory it's going to fill it
with the same data that we already have
stored here and it's going to spend time
on both the construction and the memory
allocation all that stuff and it's just
it's redundant data that we don't need
all we want is a different way to
address or interpret this data so in
order to understand how we're going to
solve this problem in an elegant way you
have to really understand how memory
works and how this is actually stored in
memory if we take a look at this what we
what we've done is we have four by four
floats so we have sixteen floats okay so
sixteen floats yeah
floats are four bytes each by the way so
16 times 4 is 64 so we've got a block of
memory which is all this and it is a
total of 64 bytes
long okay they're obviously subdivisions
here or whether you can lay this out
however you like so that essentially we
have the very first index in the array
and we have the last index of the array
but since each float is four bytes it
will be byte number 63 okay if 0 was the
first one of where this gets allocated
in memory so all this is all this
problem analysis in the way of the
FaceCam but all this is in memory is
it's just it's literally just a heap of
memory ok how we access that memory how
we decide to be like I want to access
because remember we're just we're just a
bunch of elements right so how we decide
to be like I want to access elements at
index five for example yeah all of that
is it's basically subject to our
interpretation of it so if we have a
float array what that tells C++ is that
each element in our float array is four
bytes
thus if we want to retrieve the sixth
element which is index five it simply is
going to say 4 times 5 and that is 20 so
it's going to look up byte 20 which is
for example over here and is going to
grab it and plus you know 4 bytes so 4
bytes starting at by 20 it's going to
grab that and that's going to be e at
index 5 ok that that's simply how it
works is very simple so what we want to
tell it is 64 bytes isn't that the same
size is 4 vac fours why yes it is
because remember a Veck for simply has
four floats four floats equals 16 bytes
16 times 4 is 64 so it takes up the same
amount of memory so what we want to say
is when I do something like a at 5 right
let's just say I'm like I want to get
column number 2 or something let's just
say 3 because 2 is kind of in the middle
of this so let's just say I want to get
column number 3 yeah what we want to do
is we want to be like column number 3
that'll be starting it index 48 which is
like somewhere over here yeah
and how much how big is avec for its 16
bytes so we'll end over here so I'll go
all the way up to 63 right from 48
inclusive to 63 and we're going to
return that block of memory okay and
then within that of course it'll be
divided into four okay because X Y Z and
W so all we're saying is we want to
access this same memory but we want to
interpret the divisions of it and what
we actually retrieve a bit differently
okay so how do we basically give the
same amount of the same block of memory
two different types how can we do that
well we can do that by using a union
okay so with the Union we can
essentially specify different ways to
interpret the same block of memory okay
so I can be like in this case I can be
like this union will have float elements
right and it will have let's just say
sixteen of them right
obviously right yeah and then the
equivalent in vak for which we'll call
columns is going to be four columns and
then remember these two give us 64 bytes
of memory they have the exact same
memory so that's why it's easily
unionized right it's easily addressable
we're just changing the way gets
addressed or the way it gets interpreted
okay so that's the idea that's what we
want to do again there is a bit of a
trick with getting back fours to up and
then we'll talk about that when we reach
it but this is essentially the way we're
basically we're basically providing two
different interpretations for the same
block of physical memory okay let's
implement this so to do this I'm going
to go into map for into the header and
I'm going to grab I'm going to basically
wrap our elements in a union okay so
there we go
float elements and then I'll put in back
four columns for okay this is going to
give us an error okay and as an
intelligence is going to tell us that in
value in your member class Sparky has a
disallowed member for
action okay this might be a confusing
error if we try and build this will fail
okay and it will actually say that
illegal union member so vac four has a
user-defined constructor or non-trivial
default constructor what it wants is the
default default constructor so what
happens is when you create we actually
have a default constructor well you
might seem like a default constructor we
have in it we have like an empty
constructor right a constructor that
just takes in no parameters right what
it needs is a constructor that is
actually the default constructor so if
we had no constructor at all that would
basically be the default constructor
it's kind of like the default copy
constructor if we don't specify a copy
constructor one will be provided for us
similarly if we don't construct if we
don't specify a constructor we will
still get a constructor okay so what we
want to do is specify a constructor like
this and set it equal to default okay
this will actually be a default
constructor okay so if we do yeah so if
we do build this will get another
problem and this is probably because
we've already got a default constructor
so we need to say goodbye to that go
back to
like for does he pay we'll talk about
that law we own this at the first two as
well that's terrible
it probably should be more attentive at
that code we'll go ahead and build it
and where are we
I lost a line where are we here so there
we go and that will work you can see we
get no billows we get an intellisense
errors don't worry they're not real
errors intellisense is very confused
about what what we're trying to do it
doesn't matter but the point is when you
create a mat for where's our effect for
ya when you create a constructor and you
mark it as default in this way right
it's going to it's going to actually
specify the default default constructor
which is what we get if we have no
constructor at all okay and that's what
it requires and that is it so
intellisense will still be a bit mad but
don't worry if we run this for example
it'll still run and everything will
still work as expected okay so no
problem there so now that we've done
that what can we do with this awesome
union that we have well glad you asked
because apart from setting something
like this I can pull out a I can be like
I want to vac for I want a column I can
be like give me column number position
column wise get column still thing where
are we get column so let's get rid of
get column because that was the bad way
that we don't want to do in fact let's
leave it in there because I want to show
you guys a bit of comparison and then
we'll go back to main and columns and
then we should be able to address this
as column
letting me another day weird what let's
go back to this so I call two columns
they're not what I columns okay I don't
know why it was wasn't like I guess
until it was intellisense era so it
wasn't showing up here but I can address
it like this and then I can be like
let's print this column right and then I
will cover this out and you can see that
we can get the final column which we
know is 2 3 4 1 so there we go now the
big key difference between this and say
if I used will say column 0 column 1
right so we'll print the both out as
well but the key difference between this
and just simply going gasps columns is
there's there's a there's a huge
difference okay because obviously yet
column is going to generate a whole new
thing which is going to be absolutely
annoying so if I run this we should get
the same result
right but two things I want to mention
yeah if we grab the memory address of
position door Elements 12 which we know
is positioned on columns 3 dot X right
if I grab this and I just want to take a
look at the memory address of that and I
also wanted so that's positional
Elements 12 and then I also want to take
a look at position dot columns 3 dot X
you'll see that these memory addresses
are absolutely identical right they are
the act now the actual same addresses
whereas if I did this yeah well I mean
clearly that's not even going to let
some have this to see 1 dot X yeah
there's going to be completely different
no they're actually the same what see 1
dot X is the same as position at what
no they're not the same what what they
the same was that I just see it wrong
anyway these are completely different
yeah that's the idea they're completely
different because they're it's
constructed an absolutely new thing okay
yeah I'm just gonna right click on this
and go Chantal show intellisense arrows
no thank you
huh but anyway that's the idea okay so
one more thing that we can do to check
out the difference between this it's if
I just hit a breakpoint here let's just
hit a breakpoint
mmm-maybe over here yeah I'll just run
this I'll let it break I'll right-click
and I'll go to the disassembly we can
take a look at what these actually do so
unfortunately I can't zoom in in this
view which is kind of infuriating
because you guys might have to
fullscreen there's a long thing else ooh
min so that you can actually see okay so
if we take a look at position don't get
column three versus position two columns
three let's take a look at the actual
functions let's see what is it calling
it okay so it's not calling it that's
another cool thing so Kay so this isn't
that there is no function call in this
all is doing is its setting certain
registers essentially what it's doing is
it's going to copy whatever we got there
into this we could let's get out of here
quickly and mark this as a reference I
guess we could reference that as well
well going today so if we mark that as a
reference and we go to the disassembly
okay so now this is probably a bit
better this is all it's doing yeah it's
going to basically grab the position
it's like appropriate memory yeah that's
it this get column is a bit different
it's going to call this get column thing
so if we go into that we step into it
and we take a look at what get column
does you can see the get column is doing
a lot more than what we want it's
essentially going to copy and this is
what it does in x86 assembly that's what
it does versus what we had before which
is a lot less like look at this stuff so
this is what it does right it's just
it's an insane amount of stuff and you
can see it's actually it's setting
registers pull is pushing stuff it's
it's setting a bunch of registers to
everything that we want and it's it's
essentially making a copy of everything
and it's just it's messy it's terrible
it's definitely not what we want if we
go back into here we can see that okay
quickly that's one for this a lot look
at that something so much stuff let's go
back in and then all this is doing is
that yeah much more efficient okay so
that's the idea of using unions and how
much better they are so this is episode
5.5 I hope you enjoyed it if you have
any questions leave them in the comment
section below next I'm going to take a
look at shaders and I will see you guys
when I see you which will be very soon
again if you want to catch these live
streams live just follow me on Twitter
turtlecom falls life's channel and you
can hang out in the pre-show and the
post row which I hear is arguably better
than the show itself it's not actually
but anyway I'll see you guys next time
goodbye
you